new episode of The Walking Dead aired so
if you haven't seen it
spoilers they're coming up and if you
don't want to know skip this right now
if you do want to know stick around
three two one spoilers alright well what
the [ __ ] do I know [ __ ] yeah we found
out hey Glenn didn't eat [ __ ] and die
he's alive everyone who thought he was
dead they get to eat shits their own
damn fault to douchebag [ __ ] that's me
there was a sec bye though I've been
walking with a guy named Jesus might be
hey Zeus I'm gonna say Jesus cuz it's
funnier well I guess Jesus truly does
save so it was the other dude getting
torn up Glenn crawled into the dumpster
and now he's alive because he's one of
the Immortals he's one of these Teflon
Glenys one of the unkillable there are
people in the walking dead you can't
kill Glenn is one of them but just kind
of almost a bummer because I I hoped I
thought the Walking Dead might have been
able to take that step to kill someone
who might be untouchable so yeah anyone
can die to be clear I wasn't hoping
Glenn was dead I liked Glenn as a
character I'm just saying it's always
refreshing to really feel mortality in
the characters like anyone can die [ __ ]
which is a Golden Rule I usually have it
for this one I didn't pay attention to
it's like if you don't see the body
they're alive I mean [ __ ] even Breaking
Bad season 3 it's like ooh season finale
jesse has the gun pow Gil might be dead
yeah well we didn't see the body season
[ __ ] he's dead such as it doesn't matter
if it's Breaking Bad the thing that
convinced me that Glenn was probably
alive shortly after I uploaded my last
video saying Glenn was dead was the
talking dead someone a couple of people
have tweeted me or it was in the comment
section of that video and they were like
talking dad usually doesn't in memoriam
for the people who died and they didn't
do one with Glenn that was the thing
that made me go wait a minute why didn't
they do that which tells me that
heartbroken chris hardwick thing
Rousseau's is really tough I can't
believe that habit he knew but that's
the consistency right there that
actually sold me on the fact that this
[ __ ] Glenn's alive and there were people
who were like Glenn's gonna be alive and
you're gonna eat [ __ ] and what do you
think of that
cool I get to do another video on it
it's like a guaranteed follow-up video
so part of me that wants to delete the
last video because it's so obsolete at
this point but it's kind of it's the
journey it's the path it's like I
believed that and made that video and
now that's not true I don't want to
delete it and be like never so I'll
probably keep it up I don't know who
knows I might wake up tomorrow I'll be
like oh good morning yeah that videos
gotta go who knows how it'll be able
right now I'm keeping it up we're gonna
talk about some etiquette right here
right now okay on Sunday night don't
tweet me about The Walking Dead first of
all people in New York see it three
hours before the people on the west
coast I'm on the west coast so at a
point I had to adopt a rule between 6:00
p.m. and when I see The Walking Dead I
can't go on social media because people
will ruin [ __ ] sure enough I was like
I'm not going on social media tonight
because every week since I uploaded the
videos I guess is the way for Glenn slow
but surely my fans would not spoil the
walking dead from aw [ __ ] there you go
that's why I don't go on Twitter then I
started get curious I was like I wonder
if people saw this episode saw Glenn
live and then did they go to my other
video where I said Glenn was dead and
start commenting on that I wouldn't do
that [ __ ] oh my god there they are
which means all these people that you
are seeing saw the episode and they were
like are you two gonna just kind of
flattering it away that's the connection
I have with fans even if they tell me to
eat a dick these people see something
and their first reaction is to comment
on my videos it is a bit humbling for
sure when you go on record you're like
yeah he's dead and he's not and you're
just wrong about that and it's now out
there in the universe and I know that
people have fun with that kind of
validation when they were like no he's
totally alive and you're wrong and then
they're proven right so I imagine I
don't get a lot of comments like haha
it's coming
there's no stuff in that way I
understand that so I know that's gonna
happen and I have fun with that stuff
too just don't be a douche about it so
yeah Glenn's alive I thought he was dead
as [ __ ] so I was completely wrong about
this I really couldn't have been more
wrong about this but I'll say it like
this this is how I choose to view things
like this in my life I have been wrong
about things it's not the first time
I've been wrong keep that between us but
it's true it's just not the first time
nor will it be the last time I will be
wrong again in life probably many times
and if this turns out to be the most
monumental
biggest thing I am ever wrong about in
life if this is it I have a pretty easy
life ahead of me
something tells me life's not that easy
so this just isn't as big as it gets so
I just I try to remember stuff like that
you kind of got to when you're dead as
wrong you know all your subscribers know
about it so yeah Glenn's alive he's
Teflon Glenn first of all remember the
rule if you don't see a body they dead
if the talking dad doesn't do an in
memoriam they certainly ain't dead even
now if I see Rick get shot in the head
just come and you fall down I'll be like
I I read an article once where someone
got shot in the head and they lived so
you really you don't know however that's
my question do you think a sacrifice
needs to be made do you think since this
guy we thought was dead is no longer
dead you think one of the unkillable z'
has to be sacrificed do you think
someone's going to die whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more